hey everybody Ken Coleman again next
installment of backseat driver about to
take place and I couldn't think of a
better person to put in the back seat of
this Mini Cooper than one of our
personalities here's a little hint big
guy in a little car
seriously dude you couldn't find a
bigger car in the back seat today is
financial coach and world class speaker
Chris Hogan as one of our Ramsey
personalities Chris has quickly become
America's leading voice on how to retire
inspired now the only thing bigger than
Chris is his heart and passion I feel
like you're driving a ravioli right now
I mean seriously you got room back there
done you just know I'm well I mean I'm
good cuz if I scoot any business or my
Chin's on the steering is this a real
car it's a real car they built this just
for you the good friends at Mini Cooper
are letting us use this I told him I
needed something compact and sleek well
I'm pretty sure we could drive to
Florida and back on a tank of gas the
first car I had when I got to college
was a cutlass supreme
Cola Cutlass you know I mean it was
about a block long
yeah you used up about two gallons of
gas when you started well so how many of
your buddies would hang out in that car
well we well I mean I hang out with guys
that are bigger than me right we could
go five feet if we needed to that card
in my car I do we gotta talk college
football as you play college football
absolutely favorite part about the sport
was it hurting people was it the strata
what was it I think above all it's the
camaraderie I'll never forget coach
warning defensive coordinator I never
forget I missed the tackle come off the
field and coach said Hogan you know what
you missed the tackle and I said coach
the guy was holding me the referee
didn't call the plane he just looks at
me with this just disgust and he goes an
excuse is the skin of a lie rep with a
reason and that was a life lesson
I mean think back you know back when we
were in grade school coaches impact
people's lives and so in my mind haven't
been the recipient of some incredible
coaches in my life
I like that approach I like that I won't
be able to note that I'm I'm pushing you
and I'm encouraging you but it's for you
now if I put on a helmet and some pads
and we go out on the front lawn
Ramsey solutions okay
speed which is a very fast how bad do I
get hurt if you really lower your
shoulder and hit me hard I'm not gonna
guarantee concussion but but I would say
the next two weeks is you woke up the
first thought would be Hogan something
something in your body would not
function properly led to you coming to
join our team
my wife she knew I was getting more and
more miserable banking what are you
doing at this time with Bank your every
day doing the more dip side of banking
at that time that's on my wife said well
you should go me Dave I'm thinking yeah
I'll just roll down there knock on the
door go meet if he's not busy or
anything right long story short there
was a silent auction that we attended
and in the silent auction there was a
thing called Dave's chair it's where you
had got a chance to sit in on the show
with a Sanders in behind the glass my
wife wins this thing and she goes now go
meet the man so so the question becomes
do you like to bowl my last time I
bowled I was banned from the alley I
asked you if you act like the ball this
is miniature bowling because you're the
big guy this is great so I'll start off
got her got our first one it's because
I'm so strong I got obsessed look at
this he picks it up with two fingers
honestly you eat burgers bigger than
that oh the split I'm gonna take off
these two yeah but then I'm gonna call
some action over here let's see what all
right down the middle if you were a
kicker that would be best right how does
that not go down I'm sorry just pathetic
well that's a good ball now you just
yelling at that laughing that's not fair
yeah I can't do that with my voice 66
for Coleman 58 for Hogan it's anybody's
game right now he's due for a strike I'm
telling her
picks it up so you got ten plus your
next ball see those pins are tired of
Hogan throwing the ball I just hit hit
lane services this is what happens when
you take Chris Hogan mini bowling
you broke the pins there tangle I think
they're tired
this is tired this is right now but what
the one on the web features way he's
just laying down should we leave because
we leave we should go Chris
this is why white people have an rap I
am Exhibit A as to why white people if I
never danced about you got to go
who else during the midday gets a chance
to hang out with a buddy yeah and play
some mini Pope now see we're tight this
is an intimate conversation just because
practically you're on my shoulders yeah
if we get any closer we become cousin